sí muy buenas tardes y feliz viernes
también para todos ustedes pues
efectivamente se esperaba que esta
semana el gobierno de manuel marco en
algún momento dijera cuáles son las
medidas que iba a tomar ante el alza y
ante él después de 'la del alza del
precio de la gasolina y finalmente pues
podéis ron castex como bien lo decían
ustedes quien hizo este anuncio anoche
jueves durante el noticiero más visto
aquí en el país sin embargo no se fue
por esa idea de ese cheque digamos para
pagar el combustible sino en realidad
están buscando impactar a mucha más
población porque son 38 millones de
franceses los que van a recibir este
cheque de de 100 euros y además de esto
pues la idea es paliar también pues el
golpe que está alza de los precios
generalizada de los precios es decir de
la inflación pues está dando al bolsillo
de los franceses en todo caso pues estas
ayudas como ustedes bien lo decían si
será serán para quienes ganen menos de
dos mil euros netos mensuales pero
además no solamente es para las personas
que tengan automóvil es decir que estas
ayudas van
a los asalariados los empleados los
funcionarios pero también para los
estudiantes
becarios para las personas que están
buscando empleo e incluso también para
los jubilados este dinero debe irse des
embolsándose desembolsando a partir de
finales de diciembre y hasta más o menos
febrero de 2022 y como usted lo decía
pues este anuncio vino acompañado de ese
que el precio de el gas va a estar
bloqueado todo el año 2022 se había
dicho que iría solamente hasta abril
porque se espera que a partir de la
primavera comience a disminuir el precio
del gas ya que ahora ha pasado todo ese
período invernal todo esto pues en
realidad entre estas medidas que se
anunciaron una noche más el resto de
medidas que el gobierno ya ha anunciado
durante un mes por ejemplo con ese
cheque de energía y demás pues ya son 11
mil 500 millones de euros lo que le está
costando al gobierno nacional a ayudar
digamos a que los franceses no sufran
tanto toda esta inflación y alza el
precio de la energía y del gas